just peau
après le blitz
[Musique]
nous a dit qu'il fallait sortir des gens
de boston c'est vrai on en tue à vous
boston est bien protégé mais
la zone qui l'entourent est un no man's
land
mais je ne prendrait pas ce risque dans
votre état non c'est non
tu pourrais avoir le bébé aujourd'hui
coûte en une semaine
tu crois tu peux pas de protéger mais
j'y arriverai
je pourrais mourir pour toi je préparais
pour le bébé
[Applaudissements]
on s'est mal
attrape le flanc musée
[Musique]
ou
surveille nos arrières
[Musique]
amusez vous bien il faut y est présent
et monsieur ne restera pas longtemps
bonsoir monsieur
merci beaucoup et
joyeux halloween monsieur
[Musique]
et jusqu'à noël
bien sûr joyeux noël monsieur
il était programmé pour ne pas me tuer
qu est ce qu a dérapé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ap ap la femme
ce qui a dérapé
c'est elle fait même de les avoir
fabriqués